foreign
like oh my God you ate a devil fruit now
the ocean will definitely kill you
except for these 15 000 other people
have also eaten damn one random power
Martin Scorsese here I'm just chilling
backstage right now we're talking one
piece folks on Netflix uh the last one
piece already one piece art that's what
we'll be answering all that and more uh
we're gonna be watching the trailer
starting to stop and giving you our
thoughts lon's all fired up he's salty
today I am yeah his cannons are loaded
right it was all that Scorsese fighting
yesterday I just like we're also going
to uh show you some deleted scenes and
do a q a so put those questions in the
chat we'll respond to them near the end
and then we'll tease you with next
week's honest trailer one I'm actually
having a lot of fun with this yeah it's
good something enjoyable to revisit good
for a change one piece uh look uh look
it's always a promising stuff oh it's a
problem because I was like look well I
was just gonna I feel like we need to
caveat with I I've seen plenty of Shonen
Animes in my time one piece was not one
of them I
dipped in because it was so
intimidatingly long
um was a thousand episodes yeah it's
been going on for one year a long long
time yeah yeah I'm not hitting play on
season one episode one and you know
canceling my family work and everything
else to catch up uh so this is my first
introduction to the show yes and it
seemed like this is like um I feel like
uh like an out of the loop
um you know significant other that got
taken to the 21st Marvel movie where
you're like I'm that's an important
thing for fans or the thing they did
there I'm sure that I can tell that
that's surfacing somebody yes and
they're like oh it's it there he is
slippy
um shark guys shark guys are here yeah
I don't know it was it had a lot of that
going on and beyond that
seemed like it was Faithfully For Better
or Worse adapting a children's anime to
live action yeah I'll I'll give you I'll
give you two things
I really liked the world this was also
my first introduction of these I watched
a little bit of the anime as we also
watched the live action show just to get
a sense for the adaptation how faithful
it was being what you know what what the
original was like uh but but before we
took this on as a project I I had no
previous one piece experience and I will
say I think the world in which it's set
this like planet of oceans where there's
piracy everywhere and the Pirates are
all doing a Ready Player one and they're
all very like colorful and they all have
their different powers like an anime in
Pirate world like I was really on board
I I I thought oh this is actually I'm
surprised how clever and interesting I
think
Pirates like dinosaurs uh it's a huge
travesty that we only have one major
Blockbuster pirate exactly and I love
classic swashbuckling pirate stuff
love a swashbuckle uh so so yeah like so
the the there's a lot that I think is
visually very appealing that they kind
of sucked me into this right away having
said that the choice The Narrative
choices they make the kinds of stories
they're choosing to tell in this pirate
world
not not really my thing you're only
looking for Treasure felt a little
repetitive felt a little uh you know a
little little sophomoric I just I just
felt like even after just Eight Episodes
I feel like I got the rhythms of what
this thing is and I sort of understand
how a one-piece story works and I I
don't know it felt very tropey and a lot
of cliches a lot of the dialogue is
people sort of speaking in cliches and
it just it just felt kind of wrote like
right away by episode three or four I
was like
all right all right I I get this and
like man it's such a wild and
imaginative world that's a little
disappointing well it's interesting yeah
I kind of feel the same way there was no
character that you couldn't describe uh
at least at this point in season one
there's a thousand episodes Beyond like
he's the positive one he's the cool one
she's the mean one and so forth and that
said because of the premise and where
they can just go to an island or go to
another ship and there's a whole new
world to explore I see I have more hope
for the show going forward even though I
didn't particularly love the first
season right I can see this being a
story engine for just fun
stuff going right and a lot of season
one is
clearly Foundation lay we're setting up
all of these ideas of things that have
not yet paid off at all we haven't even
seen the grand line yet not that that
makes a lot of physical sense but we'll
get uh but like yeah so I mean I'm not a
huge fan of treating season one is like
a launch like like put the good give me
the good stuff like I don't want to have
to wait for season five to meet the cool
Pirates but uh
the fireworks Pirates but um but yeah
like I I don't know like by by three or
four we're already on like an island
where there's a butler trying to steal a
rich girl's it's like a budget decision
like yeah but it's not ocean stuff but
it's not because it's directly from the
anime I like I watch some of those
episodes and it's just like I yeah I
know animes have Filler episodes all the
time we gotta kill some time let's park
here right no and that right and that is
what it kind of feels like it's like oh
man already already we're sidelined with
this like oh he's trying to steal the
inheritance but they're gonna we had to
meet the lying one first Royal his plot
and it's just like this I didn't care
about that story at all all right well
let's get into more of what we didn't
care for right here right here on his
trailers two salty middle-aged man yeah
take down your favorite cartoons
play
in a world where anime fans reject every
live-action adaptation usually for good
reason yeah
Netflix finally cracked the code change
almost nothing no matter how ridiculous
it looks
good luck with season two
one piece yeah pause I mean I'm uh even
when they stumble and fall uh I think
that's more that's a better move to do
than the old school Brian Singer like
can't do the costumes can't actually try
to replicate it try to make it look
anime I mean even when you fail it's
more interesting than trying to make it
realistic I mean I yes I I feel like
there has to be a middle ground the the
the Brian Singer approach of like change
everything just to change it because I'm
Brian Singer and I'm making a movie and
everybody's in Black now like I don't
obviously that's not the way to go and
it bothers the fans and no nobody likes
that but I do feel like the far and I'm
not saying this is true of One Piece
specifically but just in general going
way the far the other way to like take
everything exactly and like try not to
change anything because you'll upset the
I don't understand the point like you
could just go back and revisit the
original thing the whole point of
remaking something to me is revisiting
it with fresh eyes and bringing a new
creative perspective and you know
changing some things and not changing
others and playing around with it to
make something new if you don't want to
make something new just go back and
re-watch the classic thing you loved
it's there and it's Eternal and it'll
always be there to comfort you that
that's that and I know this is
generational like the younger kids just
don't agree they like seeing endless
remixes of things they've enjoyed with
new
you know whatever characters or contexts
or whatever but it's just a difference I
mean I guess yeah I still think it's
possible though to to make anime real to
take um
technology gonna get around to this I'm
so tired I really like a self-driving
cars whatever make anime real uh I just
want to be wearing way more buckles
actually wearing like eight times more
buckles I want to live in Kingdom Hearts
I want that I got like one Buckle are
you kidding that's pathetic cure all of
my wounds Daffy is that what happens uh
I don't know
I guess like something like RR like uh
emboldened me that we can go even we can
leave realism behind but still but not
have it look stupid well stupid in a
good way I don't know I I think that
they're I mean I feel like like we're
seeing more and more examples like I I
Creed Three did you see Creed Three this
year on a plane yes uh because I feel
like he brought he he Michael B Jordan
kind of he started he's bringing a
little bit of that anime visual flavor
to some of those fight scenes so I do
feel like we're getting and like uh
everything everywhere all at once had
like a little bit of a had some had some
anime energy thrown in there so yeah I
do think that we're getting we're edging
closer to that we're edging towards
anime all right we're just we're making
anime real folks it's a hundred year
project but we're gonna get there okay
keep playing here for Live Action shown
in series which is Japanese for targeted
at young boys and English horror beloved
by grown men complete with the usual
shown in troves like hungry idiot hero
one of everything please overly serious
rival I want to be worthy of holding my
own against someone like Lucy and powers
that escalate until they literally punch
God in the face trust me they all get
there eventually
in this series that Taps into every
Fan's dream that one day they too might
go outside and make friends if they
hadn't spent a thousand hours watching
the Japanese equivalent of SpongeBob
worth it
I did watch Dragon Ball growing up and
and Naruto not all of it but but enough
of it to to get the appeal and this is
it's hitting all the same beats that if
you're 12 years old you want to be
strong you want to go on an adventure
without your parents yeah and you want
to have a crew
and this is this taking off all those
boxes I can't say whether it does it
better or worse than those other shows
um I will certainly say that this is
better than Dragon Ball Evolution
um and yeah I mean this look listen
we're work we're kind of knocking it
because that's what that's what we do
but uh I this really is one of the
better live-action animes I think
without a doubt like there haven't
really been that many good I mean Speed
Racer obviously a lot of people love
like I feel like that's the kind of gold
standard but otherwise yeah there really
aren't that many good ones so it's not
really saying that much but like Cowboy
Bebop was a disaster that was terrible I
guess so I didn't like that Death Note
thing Netflix that although I don't know
that I don't know that anime very well
there's a Bleach movie that came out in
Japan that I didn't think was terrible
when is taika waititi's Akira coming out
yeah I don't that's not even happening I
don't know there's no chance that well
but yeah I mean like I like obviously
they did get a lot more right than
almost any other previous attempt to do
this it's been and having the original
Creator as an executive producer who
obviously was very Hands-On it's very
helpful clearly was a big help because I
mean like
it you know it just feels like they've
got somebody to be like hey how should
this look or should we and to just
co-sign to preempt the fan backlash it's
okay he's here
we got him right
uh all right let's keep going
but yeah I like this one's adaptation of
romance Dawn the 100 or so chapters of
the manga that took place before
anything cool happens as you're plunged
into the salty world of one piece a
franchise where you're either a pirate a
marine or
I let him keep their hands
as our heroes spend all season searching
for a map to find the grand line next up
to the Grand line do you know how to get
that this is a map to the Grand line the
grand land is just right
where is it exactly which is just this
world's version of the Equator this
spanned across the middle is the grand
line keep sailing East or West Dingus
can't miss it or are all of you the dumb
one
Choice nothing left but you said five
degrees starboard
Heather starboard Captain Fantastic ah
so does God so pause I mean I feel like
if I lived in Water World you would know
port to starboard yeah even if you
weren't a professional sailor in actual
Water World this is never an issue no
they all know they're Port from
Starbursts and they're smokers
everybody's like the Mariner they're all
guzily they're all and they're dirt
right under our Keel
but this apparently it's a strange
choice I was reading about this that
they
um the map and stuff like that small
plot point in the anime and the manga
but they kind of built it around finding
a map and following the map to the Grand
line which again in the anime or Manga
is um uh they're trying to find the
entrance to it because it's like
impenetrable except at certain places
weird detail to leave out because
they're like just it's around the globe
like a lot of people on on social media
got angry with me because I was making
fun of how silly it is in the show and I
guess in the in the manga they they do
more to make it like well you can only
access the grand line at a few points
around the globe so the map isn't just
like how to find the equator it's how to
find like this little spot that accesses
the equator which still doesn't make a
ton of sense but like makes more sense
the line tweak of like we need to find
an entrance to the ground right instead
if we need to find the prime meridian
it's like it goes all the way around
they're just describing a root a route
to circumnavigate the globe that takes
you past big cities and Islands it's
like well this wouldn't be a secret like
you could just keep sailing North or set
to figure out which pole you're close to
sailed towards the other pole and you're
definitely gonna get there there's no
geographical way
ruined uh all right keep playing meet
Monkey D Luffy
after eating a literal forbidden fruit
he gained the power to throw glizzies of
infinite size now he's on a
single-minded quest to become king of
the Pirates I'm gonna be king of the
Pirates I will be the king of the
Pirates I'm gonna be king of the
[Applause]
with only one thing standing in the way
of his dream he doesn't know what a
pirate does I mean pirate is not about
raiding Villages he hurts a scum they're
thieves and murderers not the Pirates I
know but we can't steal one what kind of
pirate are you
when you love being on boats not doing
crime that's called sailing you want to
be king of the sailors I can't let
innocent people get hurt because of me
see
um he's basically a yacht guy he just
wants to be a yacht he just likes boats
he's like uh David Geffen he just wants
to have fun don't we all want to have uh
a little boat fun yeah I mean he's uh
he's like head to the Amalfi Coast just
chill out for a few weeks this is one
area where like his performance is both
really good and really ridiculous
because he's doing anime he's he's I
mean I Credit Credit where it's due he's
doing the character exactly as he is in
the anime it's a good performance on
that low but sometimes like the line
delivery or the strange pauses and stuff
like that is because they're
um overdubbing Japanese or they're
saving money on animation so when he's
like we're friends
it's like that's that's accurate to an
animal right I mean I think that's what
the fans well like that's what I'm
saying like to me it feels like mapping
something new totally on top of
something old is like this weirdly
pointless like what's the fun of that
just go watch the other thing but
the audience clearly disagrees they they
like the idea of like remixing but but
still keeping it recognizable so that
you can be like oh I remember that
moment from the original like you see
all those like YouTube is filled now
with like side by side comparisons of
like look like we did one look how this
scene looks exactly like the previous
scene like that is a big part of the
appeal here even if I personally can't
access it yeah I guess
well it's easy
I mean yeah it does everyone's stealing
from something I mean I'm curious as to
like do the do the show Runners I mean
obviously they're delighted to be
working on something that's so beloved
and popular and like I'm sure that makes
it worth it and the money is great
whatever but like does it feel less
creatively exciting well I just mean
that something new on top of something
that was already created by everyone
stealing from something I mean like a
director before they take on a project
will make like a mood board or they'll
take shots from other films and be like
what if we uh replace the uh aerial dog
fighters with x-wings perhaps
Peterson filmmakers George this is my
George Lucas and my Jordan Peterson
what if we took the samurai swords and
made him a laser sword right I mean
those are just westerns and Samurai
movies and you had cereals yeah whatever
so it makes the job easier you're just
stealing from one piece but but I mean
this is it does it that's still Mash any
other a bunch of different things to
create something new I feel like the
goal here like they know that they've
done a good job if it's very close to
the original but this is also the the
gift and the curse of working with the
original Creator who's like no I got it
right the first time why would you why
would you change it very specifically
after like don't change anything right
yeah I thought about this very hard and
this is the right way to do it I will
say this like it is this is one piece
for
um you know for people who like the
anime but also for a whole new group of
people so he's like no like give him the
show I'm yeah I I get up here I get it I
get I get it that's what people like
it's just it's not it's not what I came
up with like it's not my kind of I I and
it doesn't connect with me as much all
right Marty
hey man it's a theme park ride it's not
a real it's not a real art that's what
theme parks are probably what I'm saying
I'm not it's all right if you like it
it's hard
who only join up after he beats them
down with toxic positivity
I'm sensing a little bit of tension
amongst the crew not a crew not me you
are our friend we are your crew Nami is
messed up because her parents died and
they one pieced her guardian right in
front of her
sorrow is messed up because his parents
probably died and his best friend at
sword Camp lost a fight to the stairs
this stuff is messed up because he was
abandoned by his dad and watched his mom
die and now he'll lie his way into
everything but the easiest score in the
East blue Sanji is messed up because he
got abandoned by his parents and his
mentor had to eat his own leg so that he
could live to kick it up a notch
you ate your own leg bam
together they'll find their way to more
themed Pirates than this universe's
laser-guided wanted posters
like the cat Pirates
the uh let's just call him Street Sharks
and of course buddy the clown Prince of
piracy who may not give up pause look
it's buggy
they call him buddy and he gets mad yeah
but his name's buggy buggy the clown
pirate you know standards and practices
and honest trailers are slipping I think
we need to do a full eval how that one
got through the cracks oh man but uh
yeah it's Not Buddy the clown you got us
uh [__] up we're very old
so old we just yeah I wasn't wearing my
reading glasses the D's looked like uh
if it was Laurel and Hardy we would have
nailed it we would have gotten all the
references right there you go uh whoops
yeah so take us to task man you got it
thank you children you should I just
called him the Joker that's what that
character all right keep going cool
jokes but that won't stop him and every
other villain from yucking it up at how
deliciously evil they are
hahaha
that's hilarious
Luffy are you gonna laugh like a pirate
with us or what I'm a different kind of
pirate uh worthless
enjoy the beginning I was sure to be a
long journey with plenty of mysteries
left to uncover like how did Luffy's
British Father Figure in Scottish
Granddad raise a kid with that accent
and give it back to me only after you
become great pirate would you expect to
be a marine when you're wasting your
time on this nonsense how you find me
anywhere will Nami get the same level of
character development she received in
the anime who will be the first to kiss
these two or these two and will all
these lovable Misfits achieve their
dreams or will everyone fail to defeat
their chronic fatigue syndrome I'd catch
up on my sleep I'm gonna take that nap
now I need to knock it off I'm trying to
take a nap you woke me from my nap
You're Gonna Keep talking or let me get
some sleep
wake up you can sleep when we get to the
next filler Arc so set sail with a young
cast of unknowns who truly embody their
characters in this absolute ship show
with a pure childlike view of the world
complicated than that I don't really do
complicate it either full of
over-the-top silliness and Whimsy that
never gets in the way of the best part
everyone butchering each other like
feral Hogs
I mean pause this has always been the
appeal of anime to me especially Shonen
or like for younger boys watching and
stuff like that or girls which is like
you get
um the plot sophistication and character
development of a Ninja Turtles or
whatever but you also see somebody's gut
spill out onto the floor yeah I mean
that's definitely they let they let them
fight right yeah like it's they don't
have our sort of puritanical American
like oh and the 18 they should shoot the
boxes above the bad guys so they just
fall on the bad guys we don't have to
have any bullets it's like no they're
just like murdering each other and this
is this stays true to that so yeah no
it's surprisingly bloody for a show that
is otherwise see you know like such a
kind of almost like a kids show kind of
vibe but then like a guy will get his
literal head bashed in on screen oh yeah
good combo just just murdered that man
let's wrap it those are brains I think
Shanks used to say not every situation
can be solved with violence oh that
sounds smart what was he from
starring Initial D aren't you glad I
didn't say bandana I was born in a
pirate ship with a bunch of apples Riff
Raff Street rat let him cook Larry
Potter Shanks For The Memories Dog the
Bounty Hunter you've been hit by you've
been struck by a smooth Emerald I think
it's two Smooth Criminal references
horror bake a leg Prince Valium jaw
Patrol that girl is
poisoned wait the butler actually did it
wake up sheeple cross dress for less the
time for weights myself I am
and the spins
stop stop the ride I'm gonna
yo ho Yoho a pirate show for tweens
I will take spending over you'd never
know that this is the same company that
made live-action Cowboy Bebop I mean
sheesh fans have gotten so toxic okay I
guess they gave one clue
so buddy or buggy buggy that's get it
right is that the guy from clerks or
Jason is that Jason Lee or no no no no
okay he sounds like him he does he's got
I can see why but no oh he's one to
watch
um all right that was this one uh yeah
that was that one pirates and that was
one piece um it made me want to watch
anime but not that one
um but uh but uh recommend uh recommend
a fun one for me um maybe shorter than a
thousand
um thank you for watching like And
subscribe hit the Bell hit the thumbs up
ring a ding ding we'll be back next week
um we have some outtakes that we would
love to share with you here they are
you're the one Jack Nero long long
silver sea monkey how can she map play
Trinity hello my name is
my friend fell down some stairs
fables yeah Chef thank you chef spry
Fieri sea salt Bay woodworking in the
food industry will do to you in just
nine years even ethniage Courage the
Cowardly Sea Dog the world according to
GARP
g-a-aarp Bad Grandpa deepest bluest my
back is like a shark's bin fish are
fiends Fleet twos ring Master and
Commander Manchester on the sea the
brave Redemption Donald stump Jr asks me
anything Kitty Pride wow those can be
boys
but no woman can beat a man
girl power and absolute ship show
sailor two
I think that's it yeah yeah there you go
all right uh let's dive into these amas
Adam Holbert starts us off with the deal
now struck with the Riders does that
mean Netflix has to admit if this show
is actually successful I don't think we
know the details yet right if they'll
have to reveal any ratings or metrics or
anything we don't have the the exact
details but I think uh it was variety or
deadlines said like it's basically going
to be there's now a bonus if you are
among like the top highest performing
shows but it doesn't necessarily mean
they're gonna just give us all the
actual numbers there will be a tier
we're gonna get a taste an additional
Taste of transparency for the for the
best performing stuff I mean they
already say they're top ten but I always
but we'll get I feel like that's fake
and and we'll get and and there'll be
bonuses for writers and creatives
attached to that rather than just like
hey here's our top ten it'll be like oh
you worked on this season this performed
at four times the level average level
you get this amount of bonus but we're
still not going to get what they really
don't want to show us which is how how
many people are watching one piece and
then how long how few people are
watching like everything else because I
mean to me I think the the thing is like
there there definitely are hits stuff
like one piece and Ginny and Georgia and
Bridgeton and like those big shows uh
it's like it's the everything else like
they're make that versus how much they
make like two percent gets into that
rarified category and then everything
else is just sitting there and you've
never heard of it which again is extra
Complicated by the fact that even those
um failures so to speak are ones that
maybe they got all you know Cricket fans
to sign up because it's a cricket show
or something like that so it's like
maybe that had more sign ups than
another season of Bridgeton and you were
already subscribed I don't know not for
me to figure out but I'm glad they do
yeah I mean I think the the the the
theory and we don't have the number so
nobody knows but yeah the theory is that
the vast majority of streaming
viewership seems to be going to the very
top tier yeah and then literally
everything else is just sitting there
but there's viewership and then there's
sign ups I don't know but even that I'm
saying like even even that it would be a
very small percentage of the total that
it we we think about this long tail
stuff like oh the long tail is where
you'll capture everybody like the the
low hanging you know the niche content
but really 90 some percent like the vast
majority of views are going to the most
popular the your squid games your tiger
Kings your Ahsoka this this one's fun
from James Bond what Let's Go reverse
what Netflix series would you want an
anime adaptation enough oh so mind
Hunter be awesome yeah that's a great
one
um hmm that's a good that's a good
question now I'm trying to think back to
my favorite Netflix originals yeah
throughout the
um was that I mean stranger things I
think obviously would be a fun
extraction you could definitely make a
Chris Hemsworth uh anime that guy would
like a like a ninja scroll style
ultraviolet oh the Night Comes for us
the Night Comes for us yeah yeah that's
already an anime
um exactly that's why it would be a cool
anime yeah uh let's see green star asks
what magic powers do you want a weird
fruit to give you oh my gosh
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna take like which
which one piece characters Powers would
would you just in general you eat you
eat a fruit you're really hungry and uh
suddenly you can uh oh boy
um flying would be cool that'd be nice
flight flight would be a fun one and it
wouldn't be like like a lot of these are
gross where it's like my whole body can
like operate in the little bits like I
don't want I don't want that like I
don't know you know like super strength
like that one guy got super strong that
would be a good or flight I think those
would be my team I mean in the world of
one piece I would settle for just not
being seasick which I do get oh yeah I
would be puking the entire time on any
boat anything is that a thing you get
over like if you if you are prone to
seasickness if you spend enough time on
a boat do you just like yeah or were
people just puking the entire way across
the ocean oh my gosh
if they just leave you on one of these
islands yeah
um well not back to November can Doon 2
be released earlier if the SAG strike
ends next week I mean if they settle the
SAG strike they could go back to yeah
but then they still have time they have
to write up the agreement they have to
vote on it so that would take some time
but then they could do promo there's a
chance I mean for Christmas I'm tempted
to say that the scheduling stuff with
everybody's schedule and whatever is
like it it's probably hard enough to
move that having done so once already
they're not gonna do it again Timmy C's
got you know a lot of different Timmy
Tim's busy yeah he's got Xbox 360
controllers to Modern
I mean God what was his name what was
his Xbox name oh yeah he's gone by by
many names over the years Mr chalamet
uh
uh tender chalamet Modded Xbox 360
controllers we found the article we
found the modded controller 360. yeah so
uh I vowed to always refer to him as
modded goodbye
Oscar winner modded controller
controller so someday soon yeah he'll be
back
um all right I think that's good we
haven't talked one piece I feel good
about it what is the one piece lawn what
do you think the one piece is is was it
in our hearts all along yeah it's
definitely like teamwork or something
it's definitely [__] because after a
thousand hours of looking for it you
know it's like if you do that per hour
then the one piece was probably not like
minimum wage you know even if it's true
it's very valuable it also again
physically like I took all my treasure
everything I earned and put it in one
piece like that doesn't make any sense
like what is it like weighs a hundred
tons like it's the journey not the
destination lawn it's gonna be like it's
the teamwork the love we developed for
one another is the one piece yeah come
on fooled again uh kind of kind of a
cynical take but not as cynical as next
week's honest trailer which is so
twisted and so in your face uh you'll
swear yeah you just walked out of the
the guy Awards
thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]
thank you